let's go next to guy from killeen texas
sky welcome
hi can you hear me yes i can
um so i had a question um that deals a
little bit more in like the
conspiratorial route um regarding like
trump's views on uh
like uh political views
okay he's never really ever made sense
to me as like a um
because i'm a democrat and whenever you
hear democrats speak about republicans
sometimes you will hear like then take
the most extreme views like on abortion
or something where um you know they say
the mother needs to be punished
um and you always say that like snl
should be put out of the job because a
lot of the things that republicans do
are just beyond parody at this point yes
so like what would make you believe like
if it ever came out in a book or
something after
trump's death or something that he was
like just secretly a democrat all this
time
just
living that caricature that they've set
out for republicans this entire time but
actually just was elected to the
presidency i don't so so here's my
thought
i don't think that so here's the thing
the idea of trump as a secret democrat
doesn't really make sense in the sense
that he genuinely did so much damage
like that would make more sense if trump
quote pretended to be a republican and
then became president and did a whole
bunch of stuff that democrats would do
but trump became president and then did
all sorts of horrible things that
democrats would never do so what i think
the scam is
is that trump was relatively apolitical
he based on where he grew up queens and
manhattan he probably was a sort of
casual
center-left guy his entire life and then
he just doesn't have the morals to say
i'm not going to pretend to be something
i'm not but he said i'm not going to win
the democratic primary i can only win
the republican primary he got some
traction with criticizing barack obama
and so
he was never a committed or real
republican in a sense it's just he's
developed this character for his
political presence out of expediency but
like the secret democrat idea in the way
you're proposing just doesn't really
make sense to me
okay yeah it was also part of that like
what you mentioned that like maybe he
was taking one for the team or something
like that in in a sense but okay that
makes sense
all right my friend thank you very much
for the call the audio i i bumped the
audio up as much as i could and
hopefully uh we we were able to hear him